The gigantic earthquake of 2011 was followed by a devastating tsunami.
The huge waves ripped up tracks, destroyed bridges and stations and drowned trains.
The Sanriku Railway was brought to its knees.
After the disaster, Sanriku Railways Atsushi Tomite came to survey the damage.
One thing immediately caught his attention.
The roads were impossible and all the cars had been washed away.
Instead, people were getting about by walking along our railway tracks.
At this moment, when everyone had lost hope,...
...Tomite realized that the railway was still partly usable.
We are a railway company.
It was our duty to get our trains back into service again as quickly as possible.
The engineers immediately set to work.
Restoring even a short section of track would be a huge help.
Just five days after the disaster,...
...trains were running again along 11 kilometers of Sanriku Railway.
By April 2014, three years after the disaster,...
...the Sanriku Railway was fully operational again.
The Sanriku Railway didn't achieve this on its own.
We have to thank the commitment of the local community and everyone who came to help.